So let's talk about voting by mail.
Very important issue in general, very important
issue acutely so right now, because if the
Corona virus pandemic I have for you today,
Exhibit A about why Donald Trump is scared
to death and completely opposed to the November
presidential election being done as a vote
by mail election.
And the reason is very simple.
Vote by mail means more people vote.
More people voting is not good for Donald
Trump.
And it is generally not good for the Republican
Party.
The example comes from Kansas.
Kansas Democrats decided to do this year's
primary or caucus as vote by mail.
This is the Democratic selection in 2016.
Kansas voted in person and about thirty nine
thousand people voted thirty nine thousand
in 2020 because of the pandemic, its vote
by mail.
And they have already had one hundred and
thirty eight thousand people votes.
And this is considering that the outcome is
a foregone conclusion.
Joe Biden is the only candidate left.
Everybody else has dropped out.
Bernie's gone.
And still with vote by mail this year, we
have a turnout in Kansas.
That is three and a half times that of 2016.
There is almost nothing to vote for in a sense.
And turnout is orders of magnitude greater
than what it was in 2016.
So we know that vote by mail in November of
2020 would be a turnout boosting mechanism.
We know that even pandemic aside.
I mean, just in a normal election, letting
everybody vote, vote by mail would likely
increase turnout.
And that's not good for Republicans and that's
not good for Trump.
Why do you think they've spent 20 years trying
to reduce the number of people that are voting?
Now, there are some other factors here which
could account for this huge rise in the number
of people voting in the Democratic caucus
in Kansas.
One is, you know, maybe there's a motivation
to vote against Donald Trump in November for
Democrats.
And it's motivating some of them early, particularly
because of the incompetent response to Corona
virus.
You've got a lot of fired up Kansas Democrats
who whose enthusiasm for voting in November
is being reflected in that.
They are also participating in the Democratic
primary.
That's possible.
But these are massive numbers.
Again, three and a half times already, the
total turnout from 2016.
And Trump recently saying on multiple occasions
he doesn't want vote by mail.
Remember this your back to us here.
You're saying yesterday about people going
to Wisconsin and voting in the middle of this
pandemic, really putting their lives on the
line.
And you said, well, if they do that vote by
mail, perhaps we'll have voter fraud in this
country as one of our voters in five states,
Utah, Colorado, why Washington and Oregon
all vote by mail to you or the White House
staff or your campaign provided any evidence
to back up your claim that mail in voting
is rife with fraud, like the example you gave
of people working in rooms filling out false
bounce.
What happened at the beginning of this administration?
Where's the evidence?
The I think there's a lot of evidence, but
we'll provide you with some.
OK.
And as evidence is being compiled, just like
it's being compiled in the state of California,
where they settled with Judicial Watch saying
that a million people should not have been
voting in.
And you saw that did excuse me wrong.
I'm just telling you, I'm telling you in California,
in the great state of California, they settled
and we could have gone a lot further.
So Trump with no real answers there, because
the reality is vote by mail is not going to
dramatically increase fraud.
And then previously, here's Donald Trump admitting
that some of these ideas that Democrats have
like vote by mail, these would mean Republicans
don't win, which may be true in the sense
that the more of the will of the people that's
represented at the ballot box, the less likely
maybe it is that a con man like Donald Trump
would be able to get into the Oval Office.
Take a look.
Here's Trump admitting it.
Just the common fact.
I mean, they have a majority in the House
and therefore, you need their vote and they
want to get certain things.
I will tell you this.
If you look at before and after the things
they had in there were crazy.
They had things, levels of voting that if
you ever agree to it, you never have a Republican
elected in this country again.
Levels of voting, which if you had would mean
a Republican never gets elected again.
This is what is being talked about.
And we are seeing it in Kansas and Republicans.
No, I mean, look, listen to their credit.
Republicans aren't wrong.
They know that if it's easier to vote, it's
not good for them.
They know that if there is less friction,
if there are fewer obstacles, if the barriers
to entry to voting are lower, it's not good
for them because the will of the people will
be more accurately represented by a larger
share.
Of the population of the United States, we
are seeing an example of it here.
All the policy that Republicans are pushing
when it comes to how elections are done is
about suppressing the vote.
Imagine the damage that vote by mail would
do to Republican efforts to suppress voting.
Not because of fraud.
Not because of dead people voting.
Not because of any of that stuff.
Simply because a larger share of the population
is casting a ballot.
So when you look back at the last 15 years,
20 years, I mean, know, redistricting, gerrymandering
has been going on for a while.
But when you look at voter I.D. efforts to
reduce early voting, efforts to reduce the
number of polling places, efforts to purge
voter rolls, voter intimidation at polling
places, constantly fearmongering about almost
mathematically non-existent double voting
voter for in-person voter fraud.
All of that stuff, plus the gerrymandering.
We now understand why.
And it's very, very clear all of a sudden
vote by mail would be devastating to Republicans
and potentially to Donald Trump.
And so that's why they're going to do everything
they can to stop it.
Now, let's talk about strategy a little bit.
This matters more in swing states.
And what I mean by that is whatever happens
between now and November.
California is not going to vote for Donald
Trump.
They're going to vote for Joe Biden, whether
it's vote by mail, whether it's voting in
person.
Turnout may be depressed if it's voting in
person and the virus is raging.
OK, California is not going to be a difference
maker.
We have an electoral college system.
If Massachusetts votes by mail or not.
Trump's not going to win here in Massachusetts.
The important states are the ones that are
always important in the system that we have.
We're talking about Michigan, Wisconsin, Pennsylvania,
North Carolina, Florida, the places that could
turn the election from Trump to Biden or vise
versa.
That's where we need to be working extra hard
to get vote by mail.
Who is it going to be up to?
Well, it's ultimately going to be up to each
individual state.
It's going to be up to the governor.
It's going to be up to the state legislatures
in those states.
This is why, once again, local elections matter.
When you look at many of the progressive successes
of the 20th century, what made sure that those
reforms stuck was having a Supreme Court that
would uphold them.
That's called doing the groundwork and much
the same way.
What could be the factor?
I mean, I don't believe it's hyperbolic to
say that the November of twenty twenty election
could hinge on.
Is there a Republican or Democratic governor?
Is there a Republican or Democratic state
legislature, if it ultimately hinges on do
they get to vote by mail or not?
Those are decisions that we can go back to
when the state legislatures were elected to
win the gubernatorial elections happen.
This is why every election matters and has
to be taken seriously.
Republicans are scared.
The numbers in Kansas tell us exactly why
they should
be scared.